hey welcome to a series here on android
studio
we're going to build an application that
will demonstrate the gps features of
your phone
so you can see the app in this condition
here
the latitude and longitude is registered
the altitude and the accuracy and the
speed
and also the address at which you're
located
there'll be a few switches here so we
can turn the service off turn it back on
switch it from the less precise
to the most precise gps settings so
that's just
ahead
[Music]
so in this application here are some of
the things that we're going to learn
we're going to be working with something
called a fused location
provider client the fused idea is that
there are multiple sources that you can
get a location
service so not just gps you can use your
wi-fi
you can use the towers and if other
applications on your phone are
getting location services your app can
piggyback
off of their work in this tutorial we'll
show how to get permissions so that your
users do not have to provide the gps
location if they don't want to
we're going to work with a class called
location request
and so this will set the preferences for
how accurate
and how often you want your gps service
to be tracked
we're going to install the google play
services and we'll talk about
what's required in making this phone
application work
this will not work in places like china
but it will work in the rest of the
world where google play services are
allowed
the application will rely on an event
listener called
on success listener so success means
successfully located myself and whenever
that happens we will update the ui or
the
user interface on the application we'll
set up a method that will start
and stop the location tracking service
and then finally
we'll work with geocode which is the
ability to translate
a latitude and longitude coordinate into
a
postal mailing address a street address
so here's a preview of what it's going
to look like when we're done
a fused location provider will give us
these coordinates and the rest of the
data
and your ability to control them and how
precise they are
so the first step is to create a layout
so i don't want to spend a lot of time
working on this layout so
take a look at what it is here all the
controls and their names
i will provide you with an xml file that
you can copy and paste
or you can build it on your own but the
point of this activity is not so much
about the user interface
as it is the more complex tools that are
behind it
so let's get started with making a new
project i have android studio looks like
version 361 as the current for right now
so let's get started with a empty
activity
so i'm going to give my application a
name something like
gps tracking demo so for my location i'm
going to put in the domain name that i
work at
so i'm at edu.gcu which is grand canyon
university
and then the name of my app so i'll let
the
build process settle down and then i'm
ready to go so let's start with the xml
activity and i'm going to the text view
for this
so where did they put the text view it
seems like they changed it on this
version so if i go to right click and
choose go to xml
i get the xml feed now i'm copying and
pasting
in all of the code that i'm going to be
including
in this new version of the app so let's
see what happens
if i click on the view to go back to the
graphical user interface view i get this
so you'll notice that for each of these
items here i have set
a specific naming convention so sw
stands for switch
tv stands for text view and let's see is
there anything else
it looks like tvs and sws are the only
thing i have in this version
but you can see the constraints are all
properly set so that the layout is nice
so you can use my xml file if you like
i'll put it in the comments below
so it would be nice to see all of the ui
elements in the code side by side so
instead of switching back and forth
between these two tabs
i'm just going to split them so i'm
going to right click up here and choose
split let's try vertically and so you
can see that
now i have two two windows to work with
so i've got xml on this side
and i can switch to java on this side so
this way i can get all of these
references quite quickly
so first of all i'll put all the text
views into place so i'm going through
each item that is not a label
so tv lat tv lawn altitude accuracy
speed sensor updates and address
are the ones i'm looking for and i
ignore everything that says label
now just a reminder of what all of these
things are that everything that has a
zero in it right now
is considered a text view
everything that just has the word listed
over on the left side
is considered a label so we can ignore
the labels they're static
now the two switches that i'm
programming here are the switch for the
location updates
and also the switch called gps the next
part
is to go inside of the uncreate method
so remember uncreate is what's called
the first time that this activity is
opened so we need to give all of these
variables
an actual id number and so those id
numbers are found
in the xml file so we're going to let
the find view by id function work for
each of these so remember to do lat lawn
altitude accuracy speed sensor updates
address gps
and the location updates so this is kind
of a tedious process but you got to go
through it to make sure that
all of these things work so this would
be a good time to test your app to make
sure that we haven't mistyped
any of these values so let's run the app
all right so if you get the app to run
correctly that's probably a good start
so we can test it out there is no
activity yet of course we've just got
the controls and their values set up
but if you have an app crash here then
double check all your work
so all of that is ahead in just a moment
for right now though let's pause and
take a break
and we'll be right back hey welcome to
part two of our application that we're
building called the gps tracking demo
you can see the app on the right we are
going to configure some of the
dependencies that are required to make
gps work on your phone
[Music]
all right before we continue on any
programming there's some important facts
that we should look at regarding the api
that we're about to use
so there are three sources of data that
your phone can get its location from
the most obvious one is the gps
satellite location
that's the one that of course works from
space cell tower locations are also
accurate
if you have a triangulation system they
can use trigonometry to figure out how
far away
you are from each tower and concentric
circles
are the idea that you can measure
distances from three points
and triangulate with pretty good
accuracy where you might be
also wi-fi locations can be used since
they are
known gps locations and you can find
locations if you're connected to a wi-fi
with a fairly good
accuracy all three of these are fused
together into a class that we're about
to use called the fused location
provider
and so we're going to build that in just
a minute
so here's some code that we're about
ready to type we're going to create a
fused location provider class in our app
and it has two different uh functions
that are going to be chained
together so you can see this one called
get last location
and add on success listener so
if a location is found then the success
listener will
create another trigger to another
anonymous function it's called
and so these nested functions
will provide most of the work that our
application is going to do
so fortunately a lot of the class has
its work
done for us we don't have to determine
which of the three services that we want
to connect to
we can give it a general idea to say be
super accurate
or be super conservative with the power
and this class will do the work for
deciding which service is in action at
the moment
so we're going to be configuring a class
called location request in just a minute
and we are going to be specifically
telling it if we want the priority to be
high accuracy and how often we want to
get the location updates
so here is what the code is going to
look like we're going to initiate a
location request
we're going to set its interval we'll
set its fastest intervals so that way
it's if there's no concern about power
we'll update every five seconds instead
of every 30
and then we'll set it to high accuracy
so there's different ways that you can
configure this
and you've got them all listed right
here in front of you
also in just a moment we're going to
have to install the google play services
so this will be a dependency in our
gradle dependency list so what is google
play
services it's far more than just the
google play store or games
as a matter of fact it's google's
attempt to regain control of an open
source
operating system so even though
technically anyone in the world
can use android freely only the
official google play services that are
installed give you the functions that
most
phones really require for example you
want your app to work with google sign
in
to work with locations to work with maps
to play games
to work with the instant messaging
systems
there's a lot of services that are built
into google play
such as showing ads and
doing some security work if you don't
have google play services on here you
really don't have a full functioning
android operating system
and so it's not available in china due
to
trade restrictions and the whole
business of relationships with
governments and so if you are building
an app that is for the chinese market
then you probably
don't want to rely on google play
services
really the only company that this
affects is huawei and so if you want to
work with
huawei they have an alternative google
play services
and you can see it here at the link
below
so now i need to go find the
dependencies that are going to make this
gps service work so i just googled this
it says android location services and
gradle which is the dependency manager
and we'll pick the first link
so about halfway through the list i find
google location
and activity recognition so i want to
copy
this link here it looks like version 17
is the current
and we're going to put this into our
dependency manager
so i copy this link and switch back into
android studio
so the place that i need to put these
dependencies is in this section called
gradle scripts
let's open the first one and see what it
says
so this is some dependencies and the
note says
don't place anything here any individual
application dependencies belong in the
other file so let's go to the second
file
and here they are so the dependencies
that we're allowed to add are down here
at the bottom
of the list so i'm going to press enter
and paste
in the location services 17.0
i can't just paste in some string here i
have to put in the word implementation
beforehand so
i'm going to paste in implementation and
then put in the little quotation marks
before and
after this and then at the top of the
screen it says you must
sync so i will choose sync now and let's
see what happens i got a configuration
successful
so that's great hopefully yours worked
as well if not then you might have to
rebuild or clean your project
or restart android studio sometimes that
occurs
but we've got a success on mine so we're
going to keep going
now let's switch back into main activity
we're going to be able to use a new
class
it's going to be called fused location
provider
client and you can see that it's
providing me some type ahead here so i'm
going to choose
this and it automatically imported
something up here on line number nine it
says it came from
the google gms location service so i'm
just going to put in the word fused
location provider client as the name
so i'll just put in a node here so it
stresses the importance
that the fused location provider client
is the heart and soul of this
application
the majority of the app's features
depend on this
this would be a great time to check to
see if the application still works so
i'm going to click the run button
and see if there are any errors with
this new class
it looks like it launched successfully
so i couldn't ask for anything more than
that
so let's keep going the next class that
i'm going to import
is called a location request so the
location request
is a config file really it's a class
that has lots of properties that will
influence the way that the fused
location provider works
so at this point we're just going to
declare that we have a new class
a new instance of this class now that
we've declared it in the top
level of our app we're going to do the
initiation down here
after we've gotten all of the values of
the ui settings
the first two things i'm going to set up
are called
the set interval and we're going to set
this to
30 000 milliseconds and then the second
item is called set fastest interval
which means if we are using maximum
power and
maximum accuracy how often do we want to
update
an alternative to putting 30 000 in here
would be to put in a thousand
times 30 just makes it more obvious
now just for showing a good programming
practice i'm going to change these
values
from hard coded in this part of the
function to
a constant so i will refactor choose
extract and constant
and both of these can be set at the top
of the page then
so after i've extracted these two i
should be able to find what i put
in up here yeah so we've got ourselves
the default
update interval and the fast update
interval is 30 and five so if i have to
make any changes later this is a
convenient location to find these values
the next item that i'm going to choose
is called set priority
and in set priority i have to specify
location request
dot and i can see some other constants
that are available to me
so by default i could set it to the
balanced
power accuracy that's probably what i
want to choose
high accuracy and low power and no power
are other choices that we can use here
so so far we've seen several things in
this video we've
imported the location request service
and we've done some configuration here
so in the next video we're going to
configure these buttons here that say
location service updates and the gps and
wi-fi options
and so that'll be coming up in the next
video hi in this video we're going to do
some more work on our gps tracking app
this is the third one and we are going
to start configuring these buttons here
that allow us to switch from cell phone
tower accuracy
to the gps accuracy and then maybe we'll
actually see some events here happen
with our location services so that's
coming right up
[Music]
so in this part of the video we're going
to start attacking this button right
here that says
gps and save power which is the ability
to switch between the gps service
and the cell phone tower tracking so
let's put in a click listener for this
guy
so to put in a click listener we go
ahead and type in the name of our switch
which is
sw underscore gps and then inside the
parentheses of our
event listener we're going to add a new
click listener
so now let's do the code for the inside
of our switch
so we're going to check to see if the
switch is checked
so checked means it's turned on if
that's turned on then we want to be
setting
this to use the gps sensors or
we call that priority high accuracy
in the vernacular of this function here
so we're going to use the constant
called location request dot priority
high accuracy
then we're going to update the text view
called sensor and sensor tells us
which service that we're currently using
and so we're using gps sensors
and of course then else is going to do
the opposite to say hey we're not going
to use the
high accuracy we're going to do a
balance between power accuracy and the
the priority of uh getting more accurate
results
and then we're going to tell it that the
sensor is using the towers or wi-fi
this would be a good time to check to
see if it actually works
so let's turn it on and run it so we've
got ourselves
power and gps down at the bottom and you
can see
that the the label is set correctly
and we hope that inside the internals
that the variable is also being set
correctly but we won't know that until
we
get a few more lines of code
all right so now we're going to create
another method and
i just want to mark the end of our
uncreate method here because it's going
to get longer and longer here
so i'm just going to put in a comment so
the new method is called update
gps and it does several things first of
all
its goal obviously is to update the gps
location
so we'll have to ask for permission from
the user before we can make this work
and then we'll get the current location
from the uh
the fused client and then we'll finally
update the ui
or the text views so that'll display all
the values on the screen
so you can see we're getting closer to
actually making this app work
so the first thing that we have to do is
invoke a variable that was declared at
the very top
of the application so it's fused
location provider client
remember this is the heart and soul of
how this application works
so now we're going to actually assign a
value to it it comes from something
called location
services dot and we're going to get the
location provider client
and that is associated with a context
and so we can either put in the word
this
or mainactivity.this
so the first thing we start with is the
permissions issue
so i'm going to put an if statement to
say if the activity compact that's the
that's the class that is our application
if that
is going to get a permission check to
say
were the grant permissions granted for
access fine location
that's the if question do we have
permissions
if we do then we'll continue on to get
those locations if we don't have
permissions then we need an else
statement
and we're going to have to go request
those so that's some things yet to do
so let's assume that we have permissions
from the user
so we're going to now call our fuse
location provider client
and use the method called get last
location
so whether that's five seconds ago or 30
seconds or
10 hours we're going to take whatever it
has in its memory
and then we're going to use an unsuccess
listener so we're chaining these things
together with dots
and then inside of there we're going to
have
another unsuccess listener item
so this will eventually feed us to
a variable called location so the
location
uh variable that you see in this
parameter will contain lots of things
like latitude and longitude and
altitude and speed and the other things
and so we'll be able to take that
location
class and update our text views
so we'll do that in just a minute that's
still a to do
so now let's do the work for getting the
permissions
so first of all there's a catch here you
have to check to see
if the value of your current android
operating system
is sufficient so we need to be at build
number 23
or higher and so the build code for 23
as you can see
is the letter m now if we have
the correct version of an operating
system then we can go ahead and get the
permissions
so we're going to use the request
permissions command and then request
permissions comes in the form of an
array
and the first item of the array is the
location or the the the type of
permission which is
access fine locations and then we need
to provide it some other number so we
could use a number one or two or three
whatever we're going to make a constant
we're going to call it permission find
locations
now you can see that we have several
things that are underlined in red
so these are errors that we must resolve
so for the first one to resolve i forgot
to put in sdk
underscore int so build version integer
has got to be greater than 23 okay my
mistake
then the other record goes away and then
finally this permissions fine
is not set so we need to make this into
a constant so we have a choice that says
make this a constant when i make it a
constant it shows up at the top here and
we have to provide it a value
so let's create something i'm going to
call it 99. you can use any arbitrary
number you want
well now we're going to have to have
another method here that will actually
go and request these permissions
so let's go up to the top of the screen
and we're going to override a method
that comes with
our activity so finding line number 20
which is our activity
so app compat activity
is the base class that where our main
activity is based on
so i'm going to right click on it and
i'm going to choose
generate and this time i'm going to
choose
override methods
now there's lots of methods that can go
into a main activity as you can see here
so many to choose from what do we want
so what i'm looking for is the on
request
permission result and what that does
is it tells the program to trigger
a method after permissions have been
granted
so let's see what comes in the form of
this
new method that just showed up here on
line 92.
so the key part to recognize in the
permission request with result
is that there's a request code which is
going to be the number
99 that i had assigned earlier and then
the permissions which is which thing did
we actually get permission for
and then the results all right so let's
get on with the code inside of this
function so first of all the
request code is important so there could
be many different requests that we've
gotten and we're only interested in
number 99
so in our switch statement we're going
to say check
the case for permissions fine
location or we could type 99 either one
will work
now if the request was from that
permission
then we are going to update the gps
so that's the function that we just got
done coding a minute ago
and then if if they didn't give us
permission if they denied them then
we'll just give them a toast message
and exit the program
let's scroll down to where the update
gps function is
so we didn't do anything here once we
got permissions so this
is a whole bunch of stuff to do we could
code everything right here we could just
update all the text views
however i'm going to provide this as
a separate function just to keep things
a little bit more compact so the new
method pops into existence down at the
bottom
of the list so it's rather arbitrary
where it goes but that'll work
and i'm going to put in a comment to see
what the purpose of this
function is this method so we're going
to update all of the text view objects
with a new location
so where's the location at so what i
need is a parameter
so i'm expecting to get a location from
the other functions so let's
put in the parameter here and then go
back and patch up the other
reference so it says you want to do
uh update values so you're missing
something you're missing a location
well do we have a location yes that's
what this
variable above us gives us location is
given
here so location location location
okay so i'm going to save that and then
let's see i don't see any more errors so
this is some to do work that
we'll have to come back to in just a
moment but don't forget
that just because we asked for
permissions here
uh they're not yet defined we have to go
into our manifest to fix those so let's
go and look in the manifest
so i'm just going to type in uses and
then magically it seems to know what i
want to do
uses permission and then the name of the
permission we're looking for is access
find location and then we close the tag
off so we can close it as you've
seen it written here or i could put in
just a
slash close and that's a self-closing
tag so either one of those will work
okay so that's the permissions i
probably don't need to see the manifest
anymore so i'll close it
now let's just finish off what we
started here we're supposed to update
the ui values so let's go add those now
so what i'd like to do is set the text
for tv lat
so remember text view latitude is what
i'm talking about
and i want to get it from the location
dot
get latitude you would think that would
work well things aren't always that easy
so the problem is get latitude is going
to return to us
an integer and set text doesn't
automatically convert
from integer to string so i've got to go
in here and parse it
so the way to parse an integer into a
string is to use the string method
called
value of and we'll surround the integer
that we're trying to get
so i'm going to do two others that are
fairly similar so i'll just copy and
paste
so the second one is get longitude and
so we'll just change a few text items
here and we got longitude
the third one is accuracy also is just
an integer that we're going to display
as a value of how accurate the computer
knows
its accuracy is now the next item that
i'm going to accomplish
is the altitude and it seems like not
every phone has the ability to get the
altitude
so we have to check to see if it has an
altitude they actually made a function
called
has altitude if it's set to true then
we'll get it
if it's not set to true it means or it's
probably null
then we will just say it's not available
the same kind of thing holds true for
speed if your phone can calculate the
speed then we'll display it
if it is not set it is not a value it'll
be null and so we'll just say
not available so we've got ourselves
this
final product almost we've got ourselves
the update val
ui values and that was called from this
method called
update gps so we could have put
all of that code in inside here and
update values
but we might want to use that again
somewhere else so that's why i separated
it into a separate function but
if you want to put it all together it'll
still work now we've got to use this
function so i've created the
update gps but have we actually called
it anywhere i don't think so
so a good place to call that would be
right at the end of our
oncreate method because everything's
been set now we're ready to do
update gps so i'm going to save this and
let's see if it'll work i'm going to run
it
alright so you should get permissions to
show up i've already run mine once
and so they're not there but i did give
it permissions
and you can see i have a gps location
here so this is the
the default location that is found in
the settings of my virtual phone
if you put this on a real phone you'll
get the location where you're at
and so it appears that mine's working so
location updates on
off is not doing anything yet we still
got that to go
the second switch is theoretically
working however i really can't test it
on this phone because it's a virtual
phone but on your real phone you can
check this out
so we've got ourselves a one-time update
it is just
checking when the app launches that's
pretty good
but we want to have the app to be able
to turn this service on and off which is
this switch
and we also want to be able to track
this
as it's turned on so every 30 seconds or
every five seconds
and so that's still some work to go but
we'll fix that in the next video so
stick around
and we'll refine our application to be
even more useful than it is now
hi welcome to part four of our gps
tracking demo
you can see the app on the screen it's
got a gps location
in this video we're going to be able to
turn this service on
turn it off and to be able to configure
how often it runs
and so we've still got some refining to
do but we'll finish this up
in just a moment
all right so we have to go and program
this button here that is the turn on
and turn off so that's a click listener
let's go into our code
and see if we can put that in our our
on create method so we'll create a click
listener
and then inside there we'll add a new
anonymous function or an inline function
called onclicklistener so when the
unclick
item occurs we will ask the question is
this
check switch checked if it's checked
then we want it turned on
if it's not checked if it's turned off
then of course turn off tracking
so i'm going to once again create helper
functions
so in this function i'm going to say
let's let's make a new one called start
location updates
which will turn on a bunch of things and
then
we'll also have the equivalent turn off
thing so we'll stop location updates
so we've got to create these functions
separately so let's go and see if we can
get some code helping
i'll click on the first item and we'll
choose generate a new
method and we'll put it in the main
activity and we'll do the same thing for
the stop location updates so we should
see
two new methods in our program so let's
make this obvious let's put in
a statement to say update at one of the
text views
it's called uh tv updates and its status
is to say hey we're being tracked
or we're not being tracked so we'll put
that in
that doesn't actually change anything it
just tells the user what's going on
now the second statement in this method
should be called
fuse location update client dot
and then we're going to request location
updates
and this method requires three
parameters
first of all it says give me your
location request
remember that's all of the parameters
such as how often this is occurring and
how accurate it should be so we defined
that a long time ago
the second item is called a location
callback
and we have not created this yet this is
going to be yet another method
that will trigger every time this
location changes
and then the third thing is called a
looper variable and uh
honestly we're just going to put the
word null in and i got that from the
the instructions in the guide of how
this is supposed to happen
so this might be a good time to show you
where some of this information
that i'm putting on the screen is coming
from so i'm getting this from the
google documentation in their tutorials
so you can see that i'm at the page that
says we're looking at get the last known
location
let's see if we've done any of this
already so it says you must
specify your app permissions and sure
enough we did that right here
we accessed they told us to use course
location
i used fine but mine's a little more
accurate than theirs
then we've got ourselves a on create we
created
a location service so we did that a
while ago
we had this same function called get the
last known location
so so far so good of course that's just
part of their
instructions let's click on the next and
let's see what comes up
so this says how to configure your
location settings let's see what they've
got they said oh
don't forget to ask for permissions and
then down here it says set up a location
request
and if you look at the code here this
should look familiar we created things
that look like this here we have
ours is 30 000 which is 30 seconds or
5000 for the most accurate and so we've
got one of these things already
configured so so far so good
so here's another page that now we're
going to get some information from
that'll help us
so we're going to get the location
updates so not just when we
launch the app but every period of time
so it says here make sure that you got
permissions that seems to be a theme in
their
locations okay then we have a location
request
so let's let's take a look here what
they're asking us to make
so create something called a location
callback and then when you have that
going we're going to have
a a function that goes inside there so
we're going to kind of use this as their
model
so let's return to our code and we need
to make a location callback so
that has to be declared somewhere let's
go to the top of our app
and let's put it in here in the list of
things that are
kind of global to our app so now inside
of the uncreate method we're going to
create
a new method that is configured here
so that is the location callback it is a
new
location callback and i'll put in some
notes here that say
that this event is triggered whenever
the update interval is met so this is 5
seconds or 30 seconds in our case
so let's see what's available that we
can do inside of the
location callback so i'm going to click
on the name
right click it choose generate
and override methods so this will tell
me everything that you can
do inside of here the two at the top
are the ones that are interesting to me
so
on location result is the one that we're
going to implement
and location availability would probably
tell you whether or not this is actually
working so i'm going to just choose the
first one
there it is so now we have on location
result
and we should get the location results
right here in this variable
so now i'm going to treat this location
result as a new value that we can update
our
app with and so i'm going to save it in
a variable called location
and then i'm going to pass that on to
the update ui
values method so that will just
redisplay all the newest values
now if you look at this you're going to
say hey why did you save that as a
separate variable and location you could
have just called it inside of the
parentheses
certainly could have so let's see if we
can make this code a little bit shorter
so i'm going to copy this
and overwrite location and then we can
delete this entire thing
so we could make it down to one line
whichever you like
alright so that should work let's go
look at one more case
when we had the we asked to turn off the
gps tracking so we should update a few
things here
so this part of the program here is to
stop the location updates
and so we're going to set the all the
properties of all the text values
to show location is not being tracked
so that is for the latitude the
longitude the speed the address the
accuracy the altitude and even the
sensor
and finally at the very end we're going
to say fuse location provider dot
remove location update so this is going
to say hey
no longer are we interested in doing the
location callback function
so take that out oh my goodness i'm
looking at my
program and i did it exactly the
opposite way that i intended to you
notice here
this is called stop location updates and
this one's called
start and the code inside is totally the
opposite so
am i gonna how could i be so dumb let's
let's copy this out of here
and put it down below and then
copy this and replace
the stuff that's up above and let's see
then we can delete
this here so i think that's a little bit
better
okay so stopping says no no tracking
starting says yes we are being tracked
and then we should update the gps
oh my goodness well let's see if that
works
all right it looks like it's running so
we have a gps location
and let's check this switch that says
hey nothing's working so all they all go
back
we'll turn it back on and we got more
locations
so we have one more part that's not
seems to be working here
it says the address and so maybe we'll
leave that for the next video but that
will be
to check to see what the street address
is based on
these locations above here so we'll come
up for that in a moment
hi in this video we're going to update
our gps tracking demo to include
the address of a location so right now
we don't have a street address
by the end of this you will
the key to make this address thing work
is we're going to use a service provided
by
google which will automatically
translate things for us it's quite
simple actually
so i'm going to embed a little more code
inside of this section called
update ui value so what we're going to
include now is called the geocoder
so it's a class that's provided to us in
android so geocoder is a new geocoder
and it needs some kind of a context so
let's put in
mainactivity.this now this isn't
guaranteed to work so we're going to
have to insert a try and
catch so if there's an error a program
won't crash at least
so the geocoder is going to provide us
theoretically with a list of
most recently seen addresses and so
we're going to define
a list of type address so we're going to
do geocoder
dot get from location and we have to
provide it a location
so we know a location it's in the
location variable
and we'll do get latitude and get
longitude
and you can see that the parameter is
asking for the maximum results and we
only care about one the most recent one
so we'll get one
now i've never actually been able to get
more than one address so i'm not quite
sure
how the geolocator actually provides a
list of things but anyway
i only care about the one that was most
recently seen
so then the next job is to provide a
text update so
we have a text view called address and
we'll set the text
so we'll get the address number zero so
the first one in the lists
so that's item zero and then as you can
see that there are lots of pieces to
that address
so we could get the county this city we
could get this zip code
we could get all those things for right
now i'm just going to get the street
address but go ahead and experiment with
the others if you want to add more
than just the address line if for some
reason this whole thing fails i'll just
say
set text and will point to the user to
say hey
didn't work now we could do the capture
of the exception and send it off
to another level but let's leave this as
a simple app
let's see what happens when i run it now
so you can see that i have the same gps
coordinates the latitude and longitude
but the location is actually
found in seattle well you can guess i'm
probably not in seattle right now
i teach at grand canyon university here
in phoenix arizona
so if you want to adjust your virtual
phone to go somewhere else you can
there's a settings button down here
there's three dots here
and it allows you to adjust so seattle
as you can see is the default location
if i want to search for somewhere else
let's go to london
and let's go to uk so we're in downtown
london somewhere
let's save the point and click ok so i
have this other point i'm going to
choose
set location so that will supposedly
set the location inside of my phone
so do i have to wait for it to update
let's see if i change the number of
seconds that it's being updated at let's
see if that does anything
let's turn it off and start again and
there it is okay so now i got a new
location
so try it on your real phone you'll
probably get better results than
a virtual phone but you can move around
the world at
light speed if you want to using your
virtual phone okay so that gives us a
pretty good starting point for building
any kind of a gps application so this
will
save a location now think about how you
would build
a real app you might have a list of
recent locations
we'll do another tutorial that will
actually put up a map on the screen and
you can show the locations
and save them as you go so you could
like leave breadcrumbs
so one more to come but for right now
this will get you to the basics of how
to get this
fused location service working and to
get permissions
so i hope you had fun this will be
another tutorial in the coming
minutes here about working with more gps
apps
in this tutorial we're going to extend
an existing application
and we're going to show maps
[Music]
so in a previous version of this gps
application
we had an ability to capture all of
these attributes of our location
we were able to turn off and turn on the
location updates
set the settings for precision so it
could use gps or the wi-fi towers
in this version of the application we
are going to have the ability to show a
list
of all of the places that we've visited
and then we're going to be able to
show a map that will point a pin point
where each of those locations is
and then finally we have a button at the
bottom that says drop breadcrumb
which means wherever the current
location is we're going to add a new pin
to the map
and a new item to the list and so that's
what we're going to do in the next few
videos
now if you haven't already completed
this application as the
gps demo then you need to back up and
there were like five different videos
that will show you how to create this
so we're on video number six right now
so i'm transitioning back to the version
of the application
that was at the end of last tutorial so
at this version we just had latitude
longitude speed accuracy and the address
we were able to turn on and turn off all
of the different options
and so now we're going to add those
abilities to have the list of things
that we've breadcrumbed and also have a
list on our map
with pinpoints so that's what we're
going to start with now
so step one here is i'm going to show
you how to add a global
address list so that way every activity
in the
in the program can see the list so what
we need to do is extend the
application class and make a place where
we can put global variables
so let's add that class now so i'm going
to switch over to the
folders where we have all of our java
applications
and let's see what i'm looking for is
where we have our main activity yeah so
this is the place
this is the folder that i'm looking for
so i'm going to right click and add a
new java class and we're going to call
this thing my application
so i'm going to extend the super class
as
application which is going to allow us
to
choose this global list so you'll see
how this works in a minute
okay so you can see that i'm using
github so i'm getting this error that
says hey
you just added something do you want to
add it to your repository you might not
see that
all right so here is our new class we
have main activity which is what we've
been working on and now we have my
application
so my application extends the
application
class the first thing we have to do is
set this
up as a singleton a singleton means that
there's only one instance
allowed and we can create the instance
the first time we call this object but
after that we're going to make sure that
there is only one
so a singleton is a is a standard kind
of uh programming method so if you
google it you'll find other examples in
other languages
but we need to have a proper or method
called get instance
and then we're going to uh assign it
this this property called
singleton which is uh instance of itself
my application
then if we go to the uncreate method so
when this thing is first made
we are going to refer to the singleton
as
this which is this class so this here is
the
properties for a singleton now after we
have the singleton created
we can add some variables that will be
treated as
singleton variables again they will be
kind of like globals
now the global list that we're
interested in maintaining here is a list
of locations
so you remember from the previous view
of this app
we're going to have a list of locations
or location
breadcrumbs and so the list type that
we're looking for
is of type location so we'll just name
it my locations
then we're going to generate getters and
setters so that way we can get the list
and we can set the list or we can add
items to it
but the point is that this list will be
a single
source of where we've been where we
dropped our breadcrumbs
so one activity can see this as well as
another
now we have to make sure that this list
is initialized so the uncreate method
seems to be the right place for this
we will create a new arraylist and it
can be empty
so at least it's not null so let's
return to the main activity and we're
going to add a new button
called drop breadcrumbs so let's come
into here where the
all the controls are and let's put in a
couple of text items and then
a button so first of all i'm going to
put in a label
and then a text view that will count the
number of breadcrumbs that we've dropped
so we could call these breadcrumbs or
waypoints they're kind of used
interchangeably here
so the first one is a label so i'm just
going to call this
text as waypoints and we're going to set
the constraints then it'll fit here
below the sensor and
it'll stick to the left side of the
screen then the next text view
will actually be the number of waypoints
that we're going to collect
or count and so this guy here will have
the text of zero
and we'll make sure that its uh
constraints are stuck to the top
of the previous label and right to the
edge of it
so now we've got ourselves two labels or
we've got two text views one's a label
and one's a number zero so what we're
going to do with those well now we're
going to count the number of items that
we've dropped in his breadcrumbs
well now we need to create that button
so we can do the dropping
so i'm going to drag a new button in so
this next new button that we're going to
put
is called the new waypoint button so
let's set the constraints so that way it
is just below the label and the number
that we've
created let's set the width so that it
extends to the left and to the right of
the screen
and the constraints will make it the
full width then for the button name
of course let's create a button that's
called the
new waypoint that'll be a good id for
the button
and that'll also be good text let's
create another button below that
and we'll call that show waypoint list
so once again we'll
set the constraints so that it fills up
the entire width of the screen
and fits nicely below the previous
button
and then a good name for the id on this
button should be like
show waypoint list and that could be a
good name for the text as well
all right so now we've got ourselves two
buttons one of them is new waypoint
and that will save the current location
into the list
and the second one is show the waypoint
list
and we'll probably get to that one in
the next video but now we want to start
programming these buttons so the new
waypoint button is our first target
so let's go into the main activity and
start doing the code
so main activity needs to have a
reference to this so let's get to the
top of the screen
where we have the references so i'm
going to add
two new button variables here the first
one is for the waypoint so
new waypoint is the id that i used and
the second one
is show waypoint list and both of these
have the prefix
of btn in the uncreate method for this
activity we need to then assign these
values to the
variables so we'll use find view by id
for each of these guys assign them and
so that now the button variables have
been configured and initialized
correctly
so now let's go ahead and program the
button listener for this button
so we will do the set on click listener
and we will add
a new button click listener inside the
method called on click let's put some
comments to see what we're up to
so first of all we're going to get the
gps location the current thing that
we're talking about
and then we're going to add that to a
global list so really that's the
focus of this video here is we're trying
to capture a list of items
called breadcrumbs or waypoints
now i want to create two class level
level variables
so let's scroll up to the top here and
the first one that i'm going to create
is a variable we'll call it current
location
and so we'll update this variable every
time the gps
is updated from the callback methods so
this will be an easy accessible
variable that all activities can get to
then we will have a list of saved
locations
so this will be a list and it'll be a
type location
and the save locations is a great name
for it
now you're wondering what is this
location thing again this is the class
that is used by android
maps and gps a location contains a bunch
of things the latitude the longitude
the altitude the speed if it's available
and so it's a class that contains a lot
of information about a gps point
all right so where would be a good place
to update this thing called
current location well i think there was
a callback method that we created
in the previous videos and let's see if
we can find it
so down below way down here we have
update gps
and this looks like the thing so this
function here or this method called
update gps has the listener in it
so we have the get last location going
on here
and let's go see if we can put this in
to our
current location so we're doing update
ui values
let's also put the current location here
as this value called location with a
lowercase
l so this guy here is the current
location so let's just save him to a
variable that's further out all right so
let's go find the
click button that we were already
programming earlier this is the new
waypoint
so in the comments in the unclick it
says get the gps location
so there should be one in that variable
called current location
then the second is add it to the global
list
so this might look a little strange but
we're going to try to get access
to this global class called my
application
so let's create a reference to it and
then all we have to do to get this
variable assigned a value is to call
get application context and cast it to
my application all right so that should
provide an access to that class now if i
want to do the saved locations
i'm going to be able to get that from my
application
and we should say there's a getter in
that class get
my locations perfect okay so save
locations now
is the little global list
now the last step is to take the saved
locations
and we're going to add an item to it
which is the current location
all right so we have this global list of
locations
and when we click the button uh we're
going to add a new item to it
now this will still cause an error we
have to do one more step that i'll have
to
show you in a minute we have to change
something in our manifest
but the the general idea should work
now i'm going to borrow these uh two
lines here and reuse them
in the ui so let's go down to the class
that says
where we're going to update the ui
values right so in this
location i'm trying to update the number
of items
in the list of waypoints so i need to
add a text view and what was it called
waypoints
count or something it doesn't look like
i've added that yet so let's
let's go back and fix that problem so
i've got to go to the very top here
and add another reference to an item in
my layout
so i forgot to do that earlier so let's
go to the text view
items and let's call this thing waypoint
counts i don't i don't know if that's
the actual name for it but we can use
that
and then down here in the list of
assignments we can do this text view
waypoint counts
okay i called it count of chromes that's
the actual name
so we'll use that count of chromes okay
now let's go back down to the area where
they're doing the updates on the ui
so near the end of the program so what
did i want to do i wanted to say the
waypoint counts
and set the text so the goal here is to
show the number of items that are in my
list
so let's do the savedlocations.size
and don't forget that we have to convert
this into a string so
i'm going to use the integer.2string
method and then we should have an actual
string that we can assign to the text
so that should update the ui all right
so i told you there was one more
thing that i have to fix so i'm going to
run the program and it should crash
all right just as i predicted the
application crashed
let's go look at the logcat and see if
we can understand
where the error is because for sure
you're going to see one of these
items when it comes your way if you're
using this global class
all right so i got way too much stuff
here i'm just gonna click on the trash
can
and let's see i'll re relaunch the app
and maybe we can get a message that i
can
find here
okay so we got the app running again and
it crashed the second time
now here is the error it says
application cannot be cast
to this thing called my application
so there it is on line 262 this thing
here doesn't work
now i promised you it would and let's
see if there is any helpful hints on it
all right so there are no helpful hints
to know what you're supposed to do here
but i'll tell you what what the problem
is let's go into the manifest as i
promised
and what we need to do is we need to
give the application
a name so let's go into the properties
and we're going to call this thing
name at android colon name and there it
is it's suggesting
my application there it is that's the
problem
isn't that a weird kind of a thing but
anyway that will cause the error to
disappear
and let's see if we can get the app up
and running now
okay there we go so the location is
right now at building 84 there are zero
waypoints
let's choose new waypoint
and let's see the ui has not been
updated so let's just shut this off and
turn it back on and there we got one
waypoint
let's do another one so every time the
app
updates and gets a new location the ui
should also update so i think that
happens about every 30 seconds right now
so i
don't want to wait 30 seconds i'm just
going to shut it off retrigger
okay so we got two waypoints now in the
next video we're going to show
that list and then the video after that
we're going to create a new button and
we'll show them on a map
so we're getting closer so what we got
here was the ability to save a waypoint
in a global list we'll see you in a
minute
in the next video hey welcome back to
another android video for gps
we're in the middle of a process of
creating an application
that does gps tracking and a demo
so we created this waypoint button in
the last video
which allows us to add a new waypoint
and so you can see that now we have
three waypoints
now in this video we're going to do show
waypoint list
and that will show all of the items that
we've saved
all right so let's get to this point
here where we can make this button
active
and show the list so let's do a
intent we'll make a listener on this
button and create an intent to go to a
new page
so i might as well stop the app here and
let's go and create that new page first
of all so let's go into the folder where
our java stuff is
and i'm going all the way down to
activity and let's choose an
empty activity so empty means you know
obviously we can start from scratch
so i'll try to name this as well as
possible so it says show
saved locations list and that should
give us a pretty good description of
what his job is
so show save locations list is going to
be very simple
let's go to its layout and then we're
going to add
only one item we're just going to add a
list view
so here it is we've got an empty screen
and i'm going into the legacy area
and choosing list view dragging that out
let's just change the
id here let's just call it lv underscore
waypoints so we know what what's in
there
all right so let's just uh leave that
alone and
i think we should probably do the
constraints so let's see if we can pin
that to the top
and let's pin it to the side and to the
right side
now i'm going to intentionally leave no
constraint at the bottom so it can
fall off the edge of the screen because
it's going to be scrollable
all right so that is the entire layout
it's going to be the simplest thing
possible and the only way to to return
to the main screen is to click the back
arrow so we don't have to create a
button to go back
but we do have to create a button to get
here so let's go back to our
main activity and let's add some items
to
this button here we're going to make
this thing a new button listener so
show waypoint list is the id number
let's go program it so back into main
activity
and let's go find a good place to put
this
so i'm thinking near the top of the
screen is probably a good location so
let's go and add our new button listener
so button show waypoint list is the name
and we will set a click listener on it
and add a new click listener
now inside of on click we're going to
have a simple program we're going to say
give me an intent to go to another
screen
so this intent should be pretty simple
as you might remember from previous
lessons an intent needs a couple of
things it needs to have the
context so the context is coming from
mainactivity.this
and then it has to have the name of the
class that we're trying to show
and so the class name is show saved
locations list we just created that a
second ago
and then we just have to tell it to
start the activity we don't have to send
any data
we're using a global lists that we've
saved and we're going to access that in
a minute
all right so there we go we got
ourselves the button listener let's see
if it works
and if it works then we can start
programming the list
all right it looks like we got ourselves
the application running let's save a
waypoint
let's do a show the list and see if this
works
all right so it shows an empty list and
i can return
to the main program so far so good now
when we go to this list here
let's actually populate it with the
items that we've saved
so as we did in a previous video we're
going to have a global access to this
list
so i need to get a reference to my
application
so my application comes from this
function called get application context
and then we cast it
into this class called myapp then once
we have that we can get the saved
locations using the getter
so get my locations remember this is a
static class or this is a singleton so
that way we can
get it from anywhere in the application
now the next thing we're trying to do is
add this list
to the list view that's supposed to be
on this page so let's create some
variables to access the list view
so let's create a variable at the top
level and we'll call it
lv underscore saved locations that might
or might not be the exact name i used in
the layout
then in the oncreate area we're going to
go
find this item in the view or find view
by id
and it looks like i called it l view
underscore waypoints
so the names don't match exactly but it
will still function correctly
so now what we have to do is connect our
list called saved locations
to the list view and the absolute
simplest way to do this is with what's
called a simple list adapter
and it's not fancy but it is all we need
for right now
if you want to create a more fancy
version with graphics and everything
go see another tutorial on creating a
custom
list adapter so then what are the
parameters inside of this
arrayadapter there are three of them the
first one is the context
so the context is just the reference to
this activity so i'll just call it
this and then the second item is what
layout or what type of
adapter are you using so i'm going to
choose a pre-defined one
and you can find this in
android.r.layout.
and you can see there are multiple
different types of layouts that are
predefined for us
now the one i'm going to choose is the
only one that i've actually have any
experience with is simple lists item
one and it will take whatever object
you're doing and make a two string out
of it so
it's not fancy but it will show the data
now the last item in the list is the
list itself
so save locations is what we're looking
for
so that should assign all of the items
in saved locations to this list
let's run the app again and let's see if
it works
okay looks like the app is up and
running i'm going to choose new waypoint
and then show the waypoint list and sure
enough you can see that there is a
location that is there
let's go back and add another waypoint
and choose show the list
so we can see one there and one there so
there are two now
so we've got ourselves a successful list
now as
you could probably argue this is a very
useless list what
can i tell from it all i can tell is
that i have a whole bunch of data
that relates to a gps location i have
latitude and longitude
the point is that i now can see which
waypoints i've saved now in the next
video instead of showing a list
we're going to put these on a map and
that will be a whole lot more graphical
and understandable
but for right now we've got ourselves
the goal that we met here of adding this
button called
show waypoint list and it's exactly what
it does
so we'll see in the next video where we
create a map and show all the pins on
the map
hey welcome back to another in our
series on our gps tracking demo
in this video we're going to add a new
button that says show map
and it will show all of the waypoints
that we've saved and put them as pins
on a google map
[Music]
so let's get started right away by
putting a button on this screen
and then we'll create a new activity
that will have the map
so let's get into our main activity area
and let's go ahead and add this new
button
so this is a pretty standard button
we're going to put the anchor points in
so that it falls next in line so
there'll be three buttons
in a row then let's set an id called
button show map with the constraints of
course
and let's do the full width of the
screen and then for the text
let's put in show map now let's go into
main activity and program this
so we need to give a reference to it at
the top of the screen and then program
it
so here we go with that reference so
after the reference variable is defined
at the top then we need to give it a
value
in the uncreate method we've got a whole
list of things that are already being
created
and so let's choose a new one find view
by id and it looks like
btn show map is the correct value from
the layout
so now we've got ourselves a reference
to the button now we have another button
that's almost doing the exact same thing
that this one is
the show waypoint this one here so we're
going to use this as a model
so let's go ahead and add a new button
listener so all the code will look
pretty much like we did
on the previous function so we're going
to have a set on click listener
a new click listener we're going to put
inside an intent in there
so the intent is going to say what is
the context which is
mainactivity.this and then we have a
problem because we don't have the new
activity that we're trying to get to yet
so this is supposed to be called maps or
something like that
but we'll have to leave it blank and
we'll go create the map
and then we'll come back and finish off
this button click listener
all right so let's create the map so
we're going to have to leave this little
error
and it says we're expecting an
expression so let's go create the
name of the class that we'll actually
get to in a minute
so let's go up to the java folder and
right click
and we're going to add a new activity
this time and let's go to the gallery
let's see what's in our gallery
so you can guess that we're going to do
an android maps activity
let's choose next we'll just leave it as
maps activity as a good enough name
and finish okay so we got this map
activity going
and it says here we've got some to do's
before we can get anywhere um
anywhere close to using the maps so it
says you need to have a
google maps api key so you have to
register your application with google
in order to make it work well they make
it so simple they have this link here
you just copy the link
and bring it into your browser so let's
bring up a new browser here and paste
that link
and let's see what comes up so we're
going to have
a registration process so if you don't
have a google account
uh you don't have gmail well you have to
get something like that
so we have a create a project here
as our option and let's just choose
continue
this will register a key name for us
that we can copy and put into our
project
so if you have to go through the
registration process of setting up a
google api that's another issue
but you're trying to get to this screen
here all right so it says your api is
enabled
create the api key and let's see what
comes up
oh perfect okay so now i have an api key
i'm going to copy that so there's a
little copy icon
and i'll just switch back into my
application
so i'm switching back and now it says
this place called your key here so i'm
just going to paste that
now your key is going to be different
than mine so obviously
don't use the one that i'm using on the
screen because it'll probably go away
all right so we got this first step
involved we got an api
key created now we're ready to go ahead
and do some programming
well where is this new class it's called
maps activity
and they've already given us some code
how nice tells us that we have an
uncreate method
and we've got ourselves a sample of
this function here they put some data in
for us
and they've added sydney isn't that nice
so sydney is located at negative 34
151 on the gps coordinates that's the
latitude and longitude so there is a
class called lat
long okay and they put a marker on this
thing called marker in sydney
and then these and they move the camera
let's see if this actually does anything
so let's go back into main activity and
now we can add the reference to our new
guys so it's called maps
maps activity come on maps activity dot
class all right so now the
intent seems to be happy let's see if we
can get to our new map
and see what sydney looks like on the
map okay the app is up and running
let's just go straight to the show map
button and
there it is we have a map and sure
enough it looks like sydney so
i'm going to try to zoom in as best i
can with this
emulator it's a little bit odd now
we're going to instead of putting sydney
on the map we're going to put the points
on that we've plotted
using our gps tracker so let's go do
that next so let's go back into our map
program so maps activity
and instead of showing the marker here
for sydney
and for this guy let's just comment them
out because
we might want to see them as an example
but we want to use our own
so the first thing i want to do is
create a variable called savedlocations
let's put it at the very top as a class
variable
and we can assign and read from that as
we need to
so we got saved locations as type list
then let's go into the uncreate method
and let's go and
assign that to the global list that
we've been working with
so we're going to create two lines that
will get us access to that list
so my application is the first variable
we need to create
and we get that from our get application
context command
then the next line down is we're going
to do save locations
equals and we will get the locations
from the global
list so now save location should have
data in it
now once we have saved locations we can
go ahead and add them to our map
so now i'd like to create a for each
loop and go through the items in the
saved locations
so when i type four each the ide helps
me out with some code typing
so it looks like in java we have to do a
colon
and that's how the for each loop works
so we have four
the first item is the counter variable
or the each variable
so it's type location is what we're
expecting and then the list
is after the colon so it's saved
locations
now i'm going to look at the example
that we used for sydney
so sydney used a type called lat
long and so that's we're going to create
as well so we'll create a new lat long
variable
and it is going to need the gps
locations from our location
item so location.getlatitude
location.getlawn
will give us exactly what we want so now
i'm going to create a new map
marker and let's take a look back at
what they gave us for the sydney example
so we're going to we're eventually going
to call add marker that's the name of
the function
but inside the parentheses you can see
that there is a variable called
marker options so let's create a new
marker options to start with
and the marker options allow us to
create a position property so
marker options dot position and we have
the lat long available
now i'd also like to add a title to it
instead of saying the marker in sydney
for the text
i'm going to create a new text and we
have the lat and long so i'm just going
to use that as the title
so that way when we show the variable or
we show the pin in the map
it'll show us the location and we we
could have put
some other thing in there but this works
as well as anything for a title
finally we do the map m-map and add the
marker
and so this should add a new item to the
list
let's go ahead and launch this and see
if it works we might have to
refine it but i think this will work
okay the app is up and running
and we're let's gonna add a new waypoint
and then let's go show the map so the
map shows up
and we have do we have a waypoint
there it is it looks to me like it is in
arizona which
makes sense that's where grand canyon
university is
now let's uh let's go back here and
let's
add another location so as you recall we
can set our location
on the gps for our phone emulator to any
place we want
so let's let's go ahead and put in
something in london
and let's see what happens if we save a
point here
and i'm going to call this thing london
so i got london in my list and i'm going
to set the location
all right so it's just like my phone
went at light speed and is on the other
side of the world now
so if i turn the gps off and on
uh it still says grand canyon university
that's not what i meant
so let's go and use this
set the location come back
and let's see what happens here do we
have
do we have a new location at london
okay let's turn this off turn it back on
let's see if we can get this to save so
in a real phone this actually works
better
so let's go and look at the list and you
can see now the last item in the list is
a different location so that that looks
good
now let's go look at the map and we
should see
something up there's one tagged in
london and there's something over here
in arizona so yes we do have two
locations now
and the list seems to be working so this
is a lot more fun with a real phone
if you go out and you follow your phone
around you can track
and place little breadcrumbs where
you've been and so this gives you an
idea of how to track and put a pin
on an item on your map now we're going
to make another video that will show us
how to click those buttons
on the map and we could create some
interaction with the map as well
but for right now we got ourselves a map
that shows our list
so that's good progress one more video
and we will show a little bit more
interactivity
see you soon hey welcome back to another
video in our android app with gps
in this video we're going to take our
map and make it a little bit interactive
so when we show the map of where we've
placed our pins
if i click a pin we can actually do
something
with it i'll show you how to make
interaction
[Music]
okay so this should be a pretty quick
video it's not really that complex of
what we have to do
so the activity that we're going to work
on is the maps activity
and we are going to program inside of
the just the java code
all right so let's um let's do two
things here we're going to do a zoom in
on the last pin that was dropped and
then we're also going to
add the ability to click on those pins
so let's come into the place where we're
putting the pins on the map that was on
the map ready
so i'm going to have a new variable and
we'll call that the last location
so this variable that i'm going to
assign is called last location placed
and for the initial value we'll just set
it to whatever sydney was
and then after we've got this defined
i'm going to redefine it
inside the loop so the last location
placed is going to be important because
it's where we're going to zoom in on the
map
and so every time we place an item in
our for loop i'm going to update the
last location placed as
lat long which is exactly this one point
all right so when i get to the end of
the loop outside of the little curly
bracket
i want to zoom in on that last location
so the method to do that is called
animate camera
as you can see there's several options
for animate camera
so i'm just going to choose animate
camera now inside of there i need to
have
something to actually configure that so
the item that i'm looking for
is called a camera update factory okay
so it's a factory
design pattern go look up factory design
patterns if you want to know what that's
all about
and then if you look at the options here
i have the first one called the
new lat long zoom and you can see that
the parameter says i can have a lat
a long and then a float value so the
float value is the zoom value
so the lat long value is pretty easy i
have that already decided
all right so the parameters i'm looking
for inside of the new lat long zoom
is the last location that was placed so
that's the
coordinates that we're going to and then
a zoom value i think you can go from
anywhere from like
2 to 20 or some range like that so i'm
going to pick a medium zoom
like 12 and i have to make sure that
it's in float float values so let's put
a 12
f this might be a good place for a
constant value but let's just put in 12
for now
okay i'm going to relaunch the app and
see if it'll zoom in on the last
location that i clicked
okay the app is up and running i'll show
my waypoint list
and it should show empty okay so i don't
have any items
let's add a new waypoint and let's see
if it's in the list
sure enough we have something i think
that's london that's what it says here
anyway right here in trafalgar square
and now let's go show the map so it
brings up the map and sure enough it
zooms in
and we're right there in london perfect
now let's see if we can
configure a new waypoint so let's go
back to grand canyon university entrance
set the location okay so it's now
set there close here
and this should update all right so i'm
just going to wait it out i'm going to
see if we can get the
location to update it's supposed to
update
okay so it takes a few minutes maybe but
as you can see i now have grand canyon
university
so like i say in a real phone it would
work better
okay so it looks like i finally figured
i got two different
locations this one's at 33 this one's at
51. we got two different spots so let's
go ahead and chose the map and the
second one that i chose was in
in arizona okay so if i zoom out a bit
you should be able to see london as well
and let's see did i have something set
in london it looks like i did
okay so go around your neighborhood and
set these pins and they automatically
should zoom in on you
all right there's one more cool thing
i'd like to show you it's the
ability to click on a pin so let's go
back and add a new item here
so let's type in map dot set and you can
see that there's a new option
called set on marker click listener that
sounds cool
that means we're going to be able to use
those pins as buttons
so the click listener item that we're
looking for is something called google
map dot
on marker click listener so i choose
new and goo and you get the help typing
ahead
and there it is all right so now we have
a new method called
on marker click and it has a marker
now the return false here is kind of a
strange thing it's just something we
have to add at the end
i think it tells the computer or tells
android that
we're we haven't actually consumed this
click it's
it's going to be used again later i'm
not quite sure what that is but
we'll leave return false as is so i'm
going to create a very simple routine
here i'm just going to count the number
of times that this
button is clicked this pin is clicked
you could set it to do other more
interesting things but this just gives
you
a demo of how clicking works
so we're going to utilize a property in
a marker called a tag
now tag is kind of a universal flexible
type of
field you can stick anything in it until
you want you can put in an integer
strings objects we're going to just use
an integer
so i'm going to say assign this value
called clicks
to be whatever was in get tag now you
can see that there's a problem here it
says
you don't know really what get tag is
but
if you cast it you will now have an
integer
as a promise so if it doesn't work let's
check on the second line to say
if clicks turns out to be absolutely
null i mean it didn't get work it didn't
get anything the the tag is empty
so if the tag is empty then let's set
the value of clicks to zero
after we set it to zero then let's
increment it so we'll do a plus one
and then we will set the tag to whatever
new variable it is
so it might be one it might be ten
whatever how many clicks it was
so the next goal is i'm going to have a
toast that will tell us how many times
that the marker was clicked
so i will put in a string for the text
that says marker
and we'll get the title was clicked
and then how many times it was clicked
is from the tag
so this should tell us a new number
every time we click it
all right let's run the application
again and let's go ahead and set a new
waypoint
and let's show the map
all right here is our marker and if i
click it
and let's see if the click works there
it is so at the bottom i have a toast
that says your marker
was clicked three times and four times
now there's all kinds of things you can
do with markers you can set their colors
you can change them to
different styles other than these
generic pins you can draw circles you
can draw lines
maps have a lot of options you can do
heat maps
you can do guided tours
so we're just barely getting started on
the maps
and so since this is an android class i
wanted to show you how to get into these
different
classes but look at the documentation to
see what the full potential is
so this extends our gps demo and allows
you to add waypoints
save them as a list show them as a map
and navigate between a few
screens so very basic of course but it's
a
great doorway opening to whatever apps
and imagination that you can think of so
good luck with your apps
in android and maps
you